I set it down on the window and I walked
up one block and I'd say oh [__] and I
turned around and it was gone I was like
I would have paid I would have paid 50
bucks to whoever had it just to get it
back it wasn't even an expensive phone
it was just the information on it and
that's the streets yeah [__] man so
Billy this is my second time talking
with you you you were a fentanyl addict
for how long
fentanyl probably about seven years but
um I've been a drug addict for 20. it
just everything progressed with time
um with fentanyl being the end result
but um I'm actually cleaning off of
fentanyl now for four months you ended
up in jail yeah I detoxed in jail and it
actually detox me pretty good I was kind
of scared and um but it was pretty
smooth it just knocked me out for a
couple of days and and the symptoms went
away
and um how horrible was it
well I've detoxed before like it's
[__] embarrassing but I had to
actually go to the hospital because I I
was on my way to go get some and I got
lost and I was in Chinatown somewhere
and I was like [__] man I I don't know
how I'm gonna get my [__] I was already
getting sick and I went to go take a
piss and like this just makes you your
guts come from the inside out and I went
to take a piss and I [__] [__] myself
I was like oh my God so I called an
ambulance to take him to the hospital
and detox me because I couldn't walk
around like that and that was just a
[__] horrible experience but I I was
weak I couldn't move I couldn't do
anything man and it just felt like my
brain was just mush and then finally
when you know they gave me suboxone but
that's not the same chemical I don't
know what's in Fentanyl but whatever's
in it it's [__] nasty man what's it
like being a homeless fentanyl addict
well
it's it's pretty easy to be honest with
you I mean because you don't it
basically just masks everything it just
shuts everything down you don't have a
care in the [__] world you don't care
about your appearance you don't care
about hygiene it's really just it just
destroys you man and now looking back in
hindsight and I've only been clean a
couple of months so you know God willing
that I I keep it going I'm too afraid to
to relapse because it's a powerful
substance
but I I just every day I just tell
myself that I I don't want to live like
this anymore and it's not because I mean
a lot of people think that you know
drugs have a lot to do with your
upbringing which I do think
but it masks a lot of stuff and I I I my
childhood wasn't perfect but it wasn't
horrible you know I had some hardships
but um
I I usually because I like to get high
you know and um but when you're on it
like there's you don't have a care in
the world and I think that's why it's so
you know so popular I mean it just feels
like the hand of God just came down to
massage your brain
and you don't care about nothing and it
feels good no depression no anxiety no
nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing's away just like a warm blanket
over you I've heard it describe that
exact way yeah it's comforting many of
the heroin but once you've reached that
like that's the most powerful [__] on
the on the on the [__] drug train of
of opiates and once you've got to that
there's really nothing above it did you
start with Heroin I started with
actually what happened was um or you
were doing heroin before fentanyl yeah I
started off with painkillers I wrecked
the motorcycle and I I [__] in I
[__] up I broke a couple of Bones and
I was growing up in South Florida where
there's pill Mills on every corner like
liquor stores
and so you could just go in and get an
MRI or and and you could stub your toe
and they would [__] prescribe you
Oxycontin you know it was so easy to get
drugs and they started me off with
Percocets and Percocets is kind of like
a it's it's not a so much a downer I
mean it kind of kind of speeds you up a
little bit and so I got I got physically
hooked to prescription drugs and then
once the prescriptions ran out you'd get
sick and you'd have to buy them off of
the street and that would get so
expensive because you'd get from taking
one or two Percocets to taking 30 or 40
throughout the day you know and then I
graduated from Percocets to oxycodone
from Oxycodone to
um heroin because heroin was cheap and
easy to get and then from there that's
when fentanyl made its big impact and
you didn't have to shoot it because I
couldn't shoot up anymore it was a pain
in the ass you could just smoke it and
you were instantly well you were
instantly High and
um most people graduate to it like
people that you hear you know all these
horror stories people dying and stuff is
is people that aren't aren't aren't used
to it you know and they're even putting
it in the in in the mess they got it in
the mess they got it they have it in
every think because they're trying to
physically addict you to it and um it's
working
but I finally got a chance by getting
arrested to go to jail and have some
time off I had uh exactly three months
off and so the physical withdrawals were
gone and it was still a mental thing but
like I'm I'm too scared to try like I I
haven't been on everybody's kind of and
I don't trust being around anybody
because people are so scared to you know
you know if somebody overdoses people
are scared to call it an ambulance
because they're afraid to get in trouble
but a lot of people don't know that
there's there's uh the Good Samaritan
law and I want to make awareness to that
like if you're with somebody and they
and they overdose you can call
9-1-1 and when they come out to that
call they're only going to deal with the
overdose you're saving a life it doesn't
matter what you have on you and I've
been I've been in that situation a
couple of times I've actually been
thanked by a police officer for actually
not being afraid to call you know and
saving a life and that was with my own
girlfriend
but um there's not enough awareness of
what's going on with it man it's a
dangerous potent [__] drug man and
it's
you know I'm I'm not I'm not I'm too
scared to go back man because your body
is no longer yeah I don't have that I
don't have that that tolerance anymore
right you know it goes away quick
and so I don't I don't trust I don't
there isn't anybody I trust being around
doing it because that's it I don't want
to die
right now like I'm clean I mean I want
to live I have like there's things I
want to do
I'm 44 44. 44. sometimes I sit back and
think me am I maybe too old but yeah man
it's never too late man never too old
and um I have dreams I have things I
want to do I just I I want to take over
the world overnight but I gotta you know
I gotta I gotta slow it down but like
like I'm capable of big things man
and I have I have Big Dreams if people
would believe in me if if I would
believe in me I could accomplish those
dreams man what kind of things did you
would you want to do
well I
I I want to do something I don't want to
be in The Matrix and working a nine to
five and and being somebody you know
being somebody's employee and being told
what to do like I like doing stuff like
that I do with you like bringing guests
and finding people and it brought me a
lot of great people people don't think
that's work you know but it actually is
working very few people you know people
try to bring me people all the time and
they bring what I call Warm Bodies yeah
people that are willing to do something
for a little bit like I'm on house you
were one of the few who brought me great
people and I enjoy it because I get to
meet interesting people you know and I'm
not afraid to come up and and Spark a a
conversation and I could tell sometimes
I could tell just by talking to them
like where their mindset is at and like
if they would you know if their goods
you know like like I like getting into
weird conversations and like not talking
about your typical you know talk topics
you know like I talk about like I like
talking about atoms and dreams and
hadron colliders and particle
accelerators and cool [__] and you know
and like but a lot of people I start
talking like that they're like oh my God
this guy's crazy and I lose them you
know so I have to find you know I and
I've had like I say a lot of homeless
people are are Diamonds in the Rough
because
there I've met so many Brilliant Minds
so many brilliant people that are
homeless that just
they've you know they've they've fallen
off somewhere and you know everybody has
a story
you know and and some people you know if
they had somebody to believe in them and
to give them opportunities like I've met
some fantastic artists
um you know people who who can sing just
people who are just very talented and
they just they just get passed up
because of either physical appearance or
because of stigma being high or stigma
of being homeless and
um but there's so many Diamonds in the
Rough and I'm one of them man
if you could ever shine a [__] I'd shine
I think it's self-destructive trait
appears in people of all from all walks
of life rich rich poor white black
everything right and it really is just a
it's luck of the draw sometimes yeah I
mean out here La actually condones a lot
of homelessness and a lot of drug use
and um because there's there's a lot of
money in it I mean like there's billions
of dollars have been donated for for
homelessness
um the Department of Mental Health the
jails everybody's making money on it you
know was it like being in jail
uh boring it's not that interesting
you're in Twin Towers yeah I was in the
Twin Towers L.A County Jail L.A County
Jail I was there for three months what
was that for
well
um it's kind of funny all right I I get
high but I'm not a I'm not a a I'm not a
criminal man I'm I'm a I'm a dope fiend
and like I'm not a thief I have morals
and like I try to earn my money I don't
like to steal or take or harm people
because I I you're not a hustler yeah I
I I just try to you know make enough to
get my fix and do my thing but I happen
to be at the wrong place at the wrong
time and there was a lot of chaos going
on
and I was in fear so I was I took off
running from a negative
there were some there were some gang
members that were chasing me and um I
didn't have too many options of where I
could go so I detoured through
somebody's house which you can't do
which was so stupid because I could have
got myself killed for that but at that
moment in time I was in fight or flight
and I wasn't thinking I wasn't thinking
that I was harming them or that I was
you know I was I was thinking that I was
just trying to
find safety and I didn't steal anything
I went through the front and out the
back you know and then when I knew the
cops were there I went back and I was
actually happy to see the cops I wasn't
thinking I just you know burglary all I
was just thinking oh all right my
options were get shot or go to jail and
I would have rather gone to jail and so
I was happy to see them at the time and
um
I don't know what happened they they
they sent me in in L.A County Jail
there's different ways you have the
general population the main men's jail
or you have the towers which basically
it's it's all you're not property of the
the Sheriff's Office your property of
the Department of Health or Department
of Mental Health and you're being housed
by the sheriffs there so I'm I'm
actually
um dealing with a lot of Department of
Mental Health and they're doing like a a
diversion for me so I don't because if I
was to get convicted of of uh
residential burglary that's what they
consider it's not a violent crime but
it's a serious crime which is a
strikable offense which you don't want
and like I have a I have a clean record
I have a couple possessions and [__]
like that but so they have a What's
called the mental health diversion and
um they had me go to mental health court
and they diagnosed me with schizophrenia
which I kinda like I I mean I'm not a
doctor but I've never seem schizophrenic
but I see this is a complicated subject
for me because where I take it I take it
to where to another level where I think
that you know schizophrenia is where
your paranoid schizophrenic and you're
hearing voices and and your you know
these voices are telling you to do
things
but with me I think on a totally
different level I'm thinking like okay
like it's some type of conspiracy but
like like if you think about it and it
kind of makes sense if you understand
like physics a little bit like we're
we're walking antennas okay we're we're
balls of energy that are vibrating at
different frequencies at all time right
and we have brain waves and now if the
intelligence people communicate a
certain way they'd be communicating on a
frequency right
so what if somebody who maybe has
certain chemicals in them that would
make them vibrate at a certain frequency
could pick up on intelligence now they
wouldn't want to you say oh okay well
this guy knows what we're talking about
they're just gonna say oh he's crazy you
know who's going to ask any questions
because I've there's things that I've
there's experiences and things that have
happened to me that sound crazy
but to me they were real and like I'm
not saying that I don't I'm not a doctor
but I've been on medication and there's
still these same
things that I'm I'm still not I'm not
too sure about
because like all right like I've I've
heard certain things like I was telling
you earlier I got I got hit in the head
um a few years back with a two by four
and it it it uh ruptured my eardrum and
so I can't hear out of it I can't hear
normal things out of it but like right
now like I can hear
you know and sometimes I can hear like
chatter like like if you're listening to
a radio station that wasn't getting a
good reception you know you can hear
like
and then you can hear people talking but
like it's just gibberish you know just
like it's a radio station that's fuzzy
and I think it's because I don't know
exactly I haven't talked to a doctor but
I'd love to find out what's going on
with it but it seems like I can pick up
certain pitches with maybe the frequency
of that I'm hearing out of I don't know
if it's high pitched low pitch but I'm
not hearing like full-on conversations
to me I'm just hearing like
like fuzz you know and there's been
times that and this is why I say it's
kind of kind of funny because there's
been scenarios okay and I guess they
would call it in an episode but the the
people that I've heard during my
episodes are familiar voices right and
it's not like
it's it's hard to explain it's like I
think it's technology and they have this
application that's called
um Google amplify
and it makes you if you don't if you're
not aware of what that is you could
think that you're hearing things because
I don't know exactly how it works but
somebody showed me a sample of it and it
sounded like somebody was talking to me
like right there but I go back to say
this that the voices that I've heard are
familiar voices that I I listen to like
on the phone like I I heard like I heard
um
uh Nick Degrassi who's a physicist why
would he be talking to me it seems like
people are like setting up scenarios
to Neil deGrasse huh is it Neil deGrasse
yeah yeah that's it Neil deGrasse the
physicist and like because I I those are
types of stuff that I watch I watch
motivational [__] I I watch stuff that's
I try to not feed my myself with garbage
I like to listen to motivational [__]
and and [__] that's like physicists cool
[__] you know just cool interesting [__]
that's that most people don't you know
talk about on a regular basis things
that are interesting but I've I've been
in situations to where
that I've been affiliated with certain
people and I think that people might
have think that I I play a different
part than I really do because what I
look like isn't really what I'm about
and being on the streets and and being
in certain neighborhoods and hanging
around certain people
they P they tend to
categorize you right and so they think
they know what's going on when I say
they I say
whoever the the law enforcement or
whoever's in charge of whatever
intelligence there is and I I'm I
believe that there's there's there's
there's there's a lot of
intelligent stuff that's going on and
they they they they use a lot of it with
homeless people because we're Expendable
if this makes sense and basically if you
are
if you are receiving Government
funding or you're receiving government
help basically you're owned by the
government and what's better to test
certain things on than homeless people
right what are they going to say who's
going to say anything to them you know
and I know this sounds crazy
but it's it's and that's why that's
where I get stuck with this I mean and I
I say all the time there's there's a
thin line between crazy and genius and
I'm definitely not a genius
but I I I I am an intelligent person I
know and I think outside the box but a
lot of things that only I can say that I
experienced and to people looking in
they're probably going to be like this
dude just [__] needs a nut
but I my experiences are real and I'd
like to talk to some some people that
have Brilliant Minds that could actually
you know maybe tell me what's going on
with myself
and I I think it's a conspiracy theory
but I hope I'm not sounding [__] I'm
just I'm keeping it real man he's got
their their ideas
and what's going on
but uh other than that man
um I'm I'm I'm back on track man I'm I'm
clean does I feel better yeah I feel
[__] great man I feel great I've I've
been exercising a little bit staying off
drugs drinking water eating I put on
look I put on a little bit of weight
and um I'm just trying to change they
say there's one thing that you need to
change when you want to get clean and
that's everything you need to change
everything
and so that's what I'm doing I'm trying
to to to hang around people I want to be
like I don't want to hang around with
people that are doing things that aren't
going anywhere like I I have things that
I want to do and I have cool ideas and
like my track record shows like when I'm
on point I'm on point and I'm not a
dummy by any means and everything that
I've ever put my mind to
I've actually accomplished but I've
always self-destructed you know but
anytime I've been given an opportunity
and I've run with it I've Done big
things with it man but it's hard finding
the right opportunities you know and
like I don't want to be just doing nine
to five stuff man I
I want to do bigger things you know I
don't know I have I don't know whatever
opportunities come that that are that
are cool I don't want to do your
conventional
nine to five every day
job what I suspect with the back to the
drug thing
is I don't think the drug addiction
thing I don't think these stories are
about drug addiction I think it's about
having that self-destructive streak
yeah that's where that's where it all I
mean the drugs are just a symptom of
that yeah yeah I mean I'm in the self
destruct industry can come from child
abuse and come from your genetics I take
full responsibility man I'm not a victim
of anything man everything that I've
done I've I've done willingly I've done
it to myself
I I don't I don't blame anybody you know
I I I'm My Own man I'm my own person I
make my own choices
and I've made some stupid choices and um
the only thing you could do is learn
from them
you know and uh that's what I'm trying
to do man every day is another day and
I'm trying to stay positive and
and do cool things and and try to
find the right crowd of people that that
want to see me do well and that want to
help me not hurt me you know it's hard
to find real people it's hard to find
true friends and true people that have
your your best interests you know in
hand
there's a
out on the streets here a lot of people
are just they just use you for whatever
they can and
there's no real friends out here I
haven't made any real friends like when
I was in jail I was by myself when I got
out of jail and by myself I'm I'm by
myself all I have is me you know I have
a girlfriend of eight years but
she wasn't concerned when I was in jail
she wasn't looking for me
she's still using yeah she didn't even
check the jails or the hospitals like I
would that would have been the first
thing I've done if I didn't if I lost
contact with her within a couple of days
you know I would have been worried as a
[__]
but when I got out of jail she was just
like oh I I called her grandfather I
didn't call her directly I called her
grandfather and told him that I was okay
and gave him my number and if she wanted
to call me she could call me you know
but um
I'm just trying to have healthy
relationships and our relationship
started off healthy but it just towards
the end it just
you know and I do have unconditional
love for her no matter what no matter
what she does or whatever I'm always
gonna I'm always gonna have love for her
because um I don't know it's it's what
unconditional love is
excellent Billy thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah you got it I
hope it didn't sound too crazy yeah I
wish you lots of luck now you're out
away from the streets
thanks